[Applause]
yeah
yeah all right I want your hands to
bleed
man I'm kidding maybe happy Thursday
everybody and it's a glorious Thursday
but tonight's big question why are young
liberals so depressed especially when
compared to their righty counterparts
the studies show it and you can see it
for yourselves do these people look like
they're having a good day
maybe if you define a good day as
resting your genitals in a bowl of
battery acid
don't knock it
so what's behind this Agony are they
liberals because they're depressed or
are they depressed because they're
liberals it's the old what came first
the responsibly raised chicken or the
organic egg
the quick answer they're not watching
uplifting programs like this one
I'm surprised Colbert's credits don't
end with how to tie a noose
very depressing
Sometimes I Cry
but to get to the bottom of this you
actually do need a former Lefty this
week Matt inglesius covered a 2022
academic paper titled the politics of
depression which comes complete with a
beautiful chart you know you can trust
anything with a chart that has colors
and numbers and lines sometimes they're
even shaped like pies so fat people can
understand them
a backhoe would say
again every Everybody laughed at that
joke has to go
but there's lots going on here so let me
simplify it for you the line at the top
the dark blue those are female liberals
and as you could see if you look closely
over the years their depression levels
have gone up faster than the price of
hamburger under Joe Biden so they're the
most depressed but right underneath them
male liberals which makes sense they're
never on top of anything
[Laughter]
yeah you know what I'm saying huh yeah
thank you but the least depressed
conservatives men and women so what's
the deal Iglesias writes some of it
might be selection effect with
Progressive politics becoming a more
congenial home for people who are
miserable but adult progressives now
valorize depression as a sign of
political commitment so to put that in
English adult liberals incentivize
Misery the worse you feel and the more
you express it the better you do in
these circles as Matt points out the
left loves misery porn and part of their
Kink is sharing it with young people
it's like Doom is their white van and
they lure in kids with Promises of
attention and street cred here's their
mating call
they challenge it the corporation's
challenging the student loan lenders
challenge it that is not right that is
not fair when liberals push the idea
that social injustice exists everywhere
and everyone's out to get you when we
live in a white supremacist world of
course you're going to be depressed on
the other hand you might get your own
Show on MSNBC but it's a self-fulfilling
cycle that feeds itself Around the Clock
like Anna Navarro
teens walk on eggshells worried about
how innocent words might get them
canceled minorities are told they'll
never succeed on their own and in seven
years the world's going to end because
bigots keep making grilled cheese on
gas-powered stoves
no wonder everyone's so angry and
depressed look at Greta thundberg
she was asked to leave a Chuck E cheese
on her fifth birthday because she was
bumming out the other customers
that's not a true story
but doesn't matter so it's not a chicken
or egg question at all it's a learned
behavior once your drama gets a
spotlight you turn it up to 11. and so
at a young age they're told the world
sucks there's no way to win and then you
get rewarded for embracing envy and
victimhood that's how you get Rachel
dollazal that's how you get Jesse
smilette but if you want to find out
what happiness looks like it's not at
rallies or at protests where being
unhinged is rewarded it's at football
games Halloween parties barbecues gun
ranges Christmas concerts people
watching raunchy comedies or listening
to comedians it's people having fun and
it's just about everything that young
leftists seek to ban remember wokism
isn't just an attack on reason it's an
attack on fun so all you young depressed
lefties watching and there's got to be
at least three of you who tuned in to
learn about relief Factor
remember the old
The Old Company and that's company you
don't want to keep happiness is there if
you want it and you can have it it's
easy it's just harder than crying like a
little
[Applause]
welcome
tonight's guests
he married a man named David to save on
towel embroidery the Reuben report host
Dave Rubin
he's busted more guts than bad cheese
comedian host of the super maximum retro
show on Vice Chris DeStefano
[Applause]
she's got more chops than Bruce Lee
eating at a steakhouse Fox's contributor
cat Tim
[Applause]
finally Six Flags converted his shoes to
bumper cars my massive Sidekicks and the
NWA World Heavyweight Champion Tyrus
Dave how old are your kids now six
months and four months wow that's
amazing they're not depressed yet no
they're not but you know what this
happens it's like if very liberal
parents I watched Family Ties where I
get a lot of my stuff like if you're a
kid if you're liberal then your kid ends
up being a conservative and if you're
conservative your kid ends up being a
liberal you could what happens if you
got two are you worried your kids might
be depressed well I'm trying to think I
grew up watching The Jeffersons so where
would that put me oh you remember Wheezy
you're moving to Chicago on the east
side to a deluxe apartment in the sky
we're gonna do the whole thing yeah uh
well I think maybe it has something to
do with the drugs because maybe they're
taking the wrong drugs the kids right
because I come from as you know the free
state of Florida right I only come back
to New York to see you and do the number
one show in late night television but
everyone's happy down there it's sun
it's freedom and all that and then I
come here and it smells like weed
everywhere right but back in my day with
the weed everybody was giggling and
laughing but everyone here seems
depressed and I'm wondering if it's a
weed issue that's interesting because I
don't I don't necessarily see a
correlation there but I will admit it's
definitely not like the weed of the 70s
it's definitely Ultra super powerful and
it does mess with your probably your
brain but I wouldn't know because you
know I'm on it right now
it's not like you smoked a ton of weed
with Bill Maher just a couple days ago
and everybody saw that foreign
with drugs is always way too successful
because if you do the drugs before
you're successful you will never be
successful you have to treat pot like a
martini that's what I what are we
talking about Chris we were talking
about a pole and this jerk starts
talking about weed do you buy his theory
well first of all I just want to say
it's my first time ever on the show so I
just I'm proud to finally be a gut
[Applause]
[Music]
it's worth six months old before
that's the definition of Irish twins
[Laughter]
if it's Puerto Rican I thought that's
because that's a very Puerto Rican thing
to have kids right away like that
because I got three little Latino okay I
did have sex with your wife but dude
now now we both so
um so no just me just me so
um what was the question Greg I don't
know yeah uh we're all doing our own
bits today hashtag gut slot do you bite
do you buy the theory is it just one
side that's depressed or could you buy
both I think personally everybody's
depressed okay I may be one more than
the other but I think everybody's
depressed I think it's got something to
do with don't get mad the 24-hour news
cycle I think you know everybody you
only watch the news when you're angry so
that they the news knows that they got a
cherry pick stories everybody's mad
everybody's mad but then they're in bed
with the ad companies so next thing you
know we're watching the news because
we're angry boom add for Applebee's two
for twenty we're stuffing quesadilla
burgers in our mouth you're getting rich
I'm getting gout and
I want to thank you for that yes I want
to come out sleep over your house
because I have no feet because you're
getting rich off Applebee's
yes excellent appetizers by the way oh I
love it dude I'm ready to die at 40
because of it yeah there you go Kat what
do you do you agree could it be the news
cycle could it be drugs I think are you
miming later
no also I look awesome so uh it's in
kind of infected everything yeah uh I
will okay I watched The Bachelor right
uh and I've noticed this season there's
like this new format where on the
one-on-one dates there's like the fun
day date and then he takes her out to
dinner and then the girl shares some
traumatic story about her life where you
know she's a single mom trying to raise
a kindergartner alone or her mom and her
don't speak or her last relationship was
horrifically abusive and then he thanks
her for being vulnerable and then they
make out through the tears and then he
hands her a rose
and after I watched this for like the
sixth time
I was asking myself what would happen if
the girl was like everything's pretty
good
my family loves me yeah my parents are
still together my last relationship
ended because like you know we just
wanted different things
would he not know what to do at this
point
I feel like it's you're expected to need
to have this kind of trauma or else you
don't deserve any respect so I think
it's almost as if they're going into
this like okay this date on TV what's
the saddest from my life that I can drag
up and cry so that he will like me but
to catch you what you're talking about
it's the same thing it's incentivizing a
behavior yeah exactly it really has and
by the way hot women don't need trauma
no no they're hot smoking hot yeah yeah
I don't even know what that means I I'm
agreeing with you I don't know I don't
know what it means either I just yeah I
love hot women
and guys and guys I want to say and guys
and other and they yeah exactly
yes you don't even see gender that's the
thing I don't I'm a baby yeah
Tyrus what's your take on this
it's not the weed it's not the bachelor
you don't have to be Puerto Rican have
three kids right next to each other I
got that covered
see at the barbecue
what messes up a good weed party when
the liberal guy comes in
everyone's having a good time and he's
like yo man do you believe the polar
bears are gonna die
like it's just what it's what they do
because what it because they have to
it's attention they need that attention
they live in the first world they don't
have real problems they're not like oh
my light Bill's about to be cut off can
I borrow your extension cords so I can
sneak behind and plugging my stuff into
the neighbors that's a real problem they
don't have real problems like oh I don't
know I just realized today that I was
born Caucasian and there's a good chance
that my great great grandfather owned
slaves and I just get out of my house
like that's not a real problem so they
they have they're bored be like us go
outside try competitive Sports go
camping fishing play with your kids
without a tablet attached to it we go
outside that's why we don't have these
problems and you can turn the 20 you can
turn the news off yeah and just go
outside try it yeah maybe not in New
York so much but go outside what it uh
that was the problem with the lockdown
the lockdown forced people to go back
inside and you saw more depression
because they weren't outside getting
vitamins they out depress each other
yeah exactly and when you're home
watching 24 hours of anything whether
it's the Bachelor or uh the greatest
cable news station in the world Fox News
you know it could be a little much sound
was lucky I was in Louisiana I had I
just had an acre I just walk out and
just be outside every day hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else